[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
premier numéro de l'année 2018 et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 3
janvier de la revue pour un jeune garçon
le cabaret du bout des prêts propose une
soirée inattendue le 13 janvier prochain
au profit d'une association un dîner
spectacle pour le jeune nathan le
festival plein feux sur les planches
revient à maurepas avec trois rendez
vous nous partirons à la découverte de
la claque et son humour caustique du
théâtre classique pour les moins de 12
ans de l'improvisation pour les plus
grands à guyancourt l'association à pas
de géants transmet sa passion à une
soixantaine d'adhérents
tony patients qu'on soit bon soir alors
vous êtes le responsable du cabaret du
bout des prêts qui orchestre la soirée
inattendue
un spectacle inédit exactement c'est un
renouvellement de ce spectacle inédit
une soirée inattendue certes mais une
soirée attendue par beaucoup de gens
visiblement presque s'en fout c'est la
troisième année
allez vous partir s'il émane espère que
le cabaret participe pour la deuxième
année et moi en tant qu'artiste je
participe pour la troisième année voilà
alors un spectacle multiples oui qu'est
ce qu'on va y voir sur scène des
danseurs et des danseuses de cabaret
déjà alors justement n'ont pas cette
année puisque l'année dernière les
danseuses étaient avait pris beaucoup
beaucoup de place pour le pour le
plaisir de tous
mais cette année ça va être plus axé sur
sur du cabaret pure avec beaucoup
beaucoup de magiciens des danses des
chanteuses des humoristes voilà il plein
de surprises surtout j'ai vu ma le
magicien max le rio chez les maux
d'estomac defarges oui comment vous les
avez contacté comment vous les avez
alors pour beaucoup ce sont des
relations amicales de la part de tous
ceux qui font qu'ils font on attend
forcément
mais
lassé des amis max c'est un ami qui
vient de très loin il va faire cinq
cents kilomètres aller-retour pour pour
le spectacle voilà mais pour lui c'est
un plaisir de venir
thomas est un jeune humoriste qui fait
partie d'un de nos spectacles et qui a
un one man show donc qui vient aussi
faire un extrait
on a on à candice parise qui est une
chanteuse qui a fait les comédies
musicales très connu en plein plan
beaucoup à découvrir le 13 janvier alors
on l'a prononcée plusieurs fois le
prénom de la personne à qui se destine
et c'est le petit nathan il a dix ans il
est atteint d'une maladie neurologique
est orpheline
comment on en est arrivé à découvrir à
connaître et bien j'étais justement
l'ami d'un ami qui qui était qui faisait
partie de l'association et qui m'a
sollicité pour savoir si je connaissais
des artistes qui pouvait intervenir
premièrement je me suis proposé et puis
faisant la soirée il ya trois ans les
parents louaient une salle il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et j'ai moi
j'ai un établissement dans lequel on
peut vous donner la salle les lumières
le son et les artistes et le repas aussi
pourquoi pas donc finalement bas tout
était tout était presque vos pieds c'est
la seule association de vous aider oui
oui parce que c'est pas évident c'est
une grosse soirée à préparer en termes
de travail c'est aussi une soirée
totalement bénévole ou beaucoup beaucoup
de gens du cabaret travaillent
bénévolement sur cette soirée on
aimerait faire plus pour d'autres aussi
mais il faut faire un choix je pense
comme comme beaucoup de people qui
souvent choisissent une association
nathan a été choisi par le cabaret et on
l'aide de la compagnie vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure c'est une soirée qui
attire beaucoup oui vie des personnes
comme nous qui veulent aller se passer
une bonne soirée et un public un peu
plus connus parfois on les savait
philippe candeloro il avait le boring
bosque cette année encore oui isabelle
morini-bosc récidive puisqu'elle a elle
a aimé cette soirée on l aime beaucoup
d'endroits aussi donc voilà donc elle
elle revient il y à quelques belles
personnalités nous avons notre
présentateur phare franck et d'art
accompagné de jean philippe doux parents
ses deux parrains effectivement d'un
journaliste de m6 compresseur oui tout à
fait et
et kaki un grand coeur c'est quelqu'un
de génial personne n'a pas besoin de
motiver viennent pas du tout venant qui
sont très très impliqué dans le projet
et même dans cette soirée
voilà qui font un gros boulot en
coulisses est faux voilà pour le savoir
injustement la la la soirée c'est le
samedi 13 janvier elle est très à
l'image du cabaret du bout des prêts à
parler de sujets pas toujours très
facile mais sortir léger c'est ça qui me
plaît si oui tout à fait oui puis faut
que les gens aient conscience que ont
fait un effort sur sur le prix mais
c'est un certain prix et le coût du
spectacle est vraiment tout pour nathan
voilà il faut que voilà donc il se peut
qu'ils aient dans le spectacle ça va
être très difficile organisé parce qu'on
a tellement d'artistes qui vont se
chevaucher avec très peu de répétitions
mais je pense que tout le monde sera
indulgent et passerez une très belle
soirée s'annonce fission agit souvent un
cabaret dans les yvelines comment est-ce
qu'on en vient à créer une telle
structure
ça peut paraître étonnant même si ça se
développe se développent un petit peu
comme des champignons et c'est
clairement dans toute la france et c'est
très bien parce que le cabaret parisien
donne accès aussi beaucoup à l'étranger
beaucoup d'étrangers viennent et les
français souvent
se disent bas c'est un petit peu trop
cher pour nous et tout ça donc les
cabarets de province donne accès à la
proximité les gens viennent de la région
de plus en plus chez nous et on a été
moi j'ai été parachuté en fait je
travaillais dans la ferme qui était à
côté
et puis j'ai vu cette grange qui était à
l'abandon et et on a fait ce magnifique
cabaret voilà et justement vous proposer
cinq spectacles avant d'en parler un peu
plus je propose qu'on regarde un petit
making of
il
on l'a vu c'est très dans la lignée lido
moulin rouge crazy horse et vos
inspirations complètement ces
établissements qu'on aime aller voir et
on va pas dire qu'on copie bien
évidemment mais on s'inspire forcément
de ces belles choses on n'a pas le même
effectif on n'a pas les mêmes budgets
mais on n'a même pas s'il est le même
professionnalisme aussi oui c'est
justement vous êtes professionnel
oui tous les gens qui sont sur scène
sont professionnelles même aussi à
l'extérieur
l'accueil la cuisine tous assez
professionnel et c'est compliqué à gérer
mais bien sa place et anthony bastien
alors sur la soirée inattendue juste
c'est le 13 janvier au cabaret du bout
des prêts à cerner la ville est lui
aussi les cinq spectacles à découvrir
tout au long de l'année
on reste à cerner la ville parce que
pour les plus jeunes d'entre nous c'est
encore les vacances pendant quelques
jours alors c'est l'occasion d'aller
écouter pourquoi pas un conte au petit
moulin caroline julie vous emmène dans
un voyage peuplé de galettes et de petit
pot de beurre
on y suit un joueur de violon parti de
chez lui et côté je raconte les grandes
questions universelles et intemporelles
donc les peurs les joies les surprises
des impatiences et la vie de tous les
jours c'est la vie des hommes depuis des
milliers d'années finalement on compte
depuis toujours et j'aime bien marcher
dans la nature je fais des balades
contées également et donc approchant ce
petit moulin j'ai trouvé cela absolument
délicieux je trouve que la muséographie
est à la fois très sobre mais très belle
avec le bois des matériaux et cela porte
à la sérénité a renvoyé le château se
visite en parcours théâtralisé jusqu'au
6 janvier suivez louise va ten une
domestique qui prépare l'arrivée du
président félix faure
entre noël et jour de l'an le public du
château a pu découvrir ou redécouvrir
l'histoire du château de rambures 8 de
rambouillet grâce à contes et histoires
une immersion historique avec l'un des
contes les plus célèbres de l'époque
michael est lui d'euros pour les images
vous rassure
va bien parce que le chef de rambouillet
et un château mais ge et la magie de
noël cette année à envoyer les enfants
au xviiie siècle au temps de louis jean
marie petit fils de louis xiv contes et
histoires fait visiter les monuments
nationaux autrement c'est les anecdotes
c'est l'histoire de toutes ces personnes
qui ont vécu ici qui est importante et
le petit duc de penthièvre est né à
rambouillet et du coup c'est une partie
de lui qui est ici et c'est important de
faire vivre un petit duc éduqué par le
comte la leçon du jour est l'un des
contes les plus connus la belle et la
bête écrit par jeanne marie leprince de
bon non mise en scène aujourd'hui par
une troupe et blinoise
[Musique]
on a été soucieux de rester fidèle au
texte à l'auteur du xviiie siècle et est
un petit peu de redonner cette version
traditionnelle qui a complètement été
déformés avec le film qui est sorti
récemment ou encore le le dessin animé
qui a sorti il ya une vingtaine d'années
il ya un rythme lent il ya un rythme
très poétique
ça c'est vraiment ce qu'a voulu le
metteur en scène monique fonds didion
verdict à la sortie j'aimerais bien ce
point si on est quatre alors j'aime bien
ça et les costumes
car il était assez ferrer qui on ne
saurait imaginer dans la pièce pour
cette troisième édition de contes et
histoires près de 450 personnes ont
voyagé avec le petit duc de penthièvre
la troupe du crâne que l'on vient de
voir sur le sujet sera sur la scène de
l'espace albert camus de maurepas le 13
janvier prochain dans le cadre du
festival plein feux sur les planches un
festif à un festival auquel participent
notre nouvel invité damien croiser au
bonjour bonsoir alors président de
l'association la claque tout à fait mort
pas elle aussi une association créée en
2013 c'est savez une petite association
une une dizaine de personnes et l'idée
en fait de la claque c'était d'écrire
nous mêmes nos pièces de théâtre donc
depuis 2013 on est à notre troisième
création
on a fait plus tôt
plutôt des sketches on a écrit une
grosse pièce et là on retombe sur un
format plutôt plutôt sketches mais avec
un fil conducteur
en outre chaque sketch justement
d'écrire une pièce originale ça comment
ça se passe vous avez eu des cours
d'écriture c'est une passion comment
vous faites
c'était plus une envie en fait
de pouvoir dire tout ce qu'on avait
envie de pouvoir de vouloir dire qu'on
trouvait pas forcément un été qui était
déjà écrit et puis on a un peu tâtonné
au début en de trouver une bonne méthode
pour écrire mais mais on a on a fini par
par trouver quelque chose et ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est assez collectif brainstorm tous
ensemble et après chacun prend des idées
qui l'intéressent écrit dans son coin
revient très collégial très très
collaboratif et et chacun amène sa pâte
y en a qui sont un petit peu moins doués
pour écrire mais quand même des idées et
qu'il est qui les amène donc c'est ça
qui est plutôt bien fait pas tout le
monde participe récents en 2013 déjà
entre 8 et 12 en fonction des pièces et
vous avez un mode en rire oui nous on
aime écrire des pièces qui font rire un
peu décalé dans l'air du temps voilà on
vient au théâtre pour se marrer donc
c'est ça qu'on veut faire passer comme
message et on écrit pour cent d'entre
elles je propose qu'on regarde un petit
extrait une petite présentation rapide
de l'association
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes plusieurs à écrire tous
mais est ce que quelqu'un chapeaute
quand même pour encadrer un peu tout ça
oui oui c'est un peu moi qui chapeaute
tout ça et qui gère un peu un peu cette
troupe mais comme on n'est pas beaucoup
aussi on essaye quand même d'avoir une
une gestion plus tôt collective alors ça
reste une association donc enfin ça
c'est moi le président un trésorier une
secrétaire mais tout ce qui est gestion
on essaye quand même d'être de faire
tout ça ensemble et de que tout le monde
soit au courant de tout voilà une
association de passionnés parce que vous
êtes tous bénévoles en plus exactement
sur autant c'est ça les enfants d'hier
et périscolaire c'est pour ça que ça
prend aussi beaucoup de temps à écrire
on a pris presque un petit peu plus d'un
an là pour pourrir mais on se voit une
fois une fois par semaine officiellement
le jeudi soir alors quelquefois le
dimanche en petit comité très restreint
quand il faut mettre un petit coup de
boost ou ou avancer un peu plus mais
ouais c'est faut que ça reste un loisir
aussi donc on peut pas demander à des
gens qui ont une famille des enfants
d'être d'être présent tous les jours
parce que ça s'apprend aussi beaucoup de
temps d'écrire en fait c'est justement
accélérer le 26 janvier prochain plus
très longtemps
vous présentez votre dernier création
c'est quand qu'on arrive voilà c'est
quand qu'on arrive donc c'est une pièce
sur les vacances voilà on avait envie de
parler de de vacances on s'est dit les
vacances c'est sympa ça parle à tout le
monde
tout le monde a des petites anecdotes
sur les vacances sur ce qu'il peut
arriver donc donc c'est aussi pour nous
plus facile d'écrire parce que ben a
parlé de vacances tout le monde a
forcément une histoire racontée sur des
vacances qu'il a passé ou qui l'ont
entendue par un copain pour ça donc des
situations déjà vécues mais je comprends
que vous parlez un peu loin
oui des situations déjà vécues là on en
rajoute un petit peu pour pour faire
rire mais comme on est aussi dans le
doute et être un peu absurde là par
exemple dans le spectacle on a imaginé
une conversation entre deux moustiques
pendant pendant les vacances
exactement tout à fait donc donc vous
verrez 7,26 le 26 janvier un humour
caustique comme ça un peu décalé vous
avez des références peut-être
professionnelle ou où justement vous
cherchez à ne pas vous baser sur ce
qu'ont pu faire les déjà des grands noms
en fait quand on a écrit on sait pas dit
tiens on va les voir à tel artiste au
talent artistique a peut-être déjà fait
ça ou quoi on est vraiment parti de ce
que nous on connaissait de notre
expérience personnelle de on n'a pas été
fouillé en tout cas il y avait des gens
tellement d'idées en fait quand on a
fait le brainstorming s'est retrouvé
avec des pages et des pages d'idées de
personnages de situation de lieux que on
n'a pas eu besoin d'aller voir ailleurs
pour pour nous inspirer
alors justement là vous jouez pour
pleins feux sur les planches vous c'est
le 26 janvier alors que c'est la
représentation mais pas seulement
vous avez le droit à une résidence c'est
ça en fait c est ce que ça vous apporte
vous bah c'est un vrai plus en fait
parce que du coup on a toutes là toute
la semaine pour pour répéter pour
préparer le spectacle
en fait on l'a où on répète actuellement
nous faisons une petite salle qui fait 7
mètres de large
on va passer à une grande scène qui fait
à peu près à prendre pour faire ça donc
il ya plein de petites adaptations à
faire
qu'on peut pas faire dans la salle on me
répète c'est la résidence nous sert nous
sert à ça et alors est ce que vous
accueillez encore du monde ou est ce que
vous êtes complet non on accueille en
accueille de nouveaux membres en fait
tous les ans et ce qui est plutôt aussi
pratique dans le fait qu'on écrive ce
qu'on peut écrire aussi du sur mesure
on a des gens qui arrivent et qui c'est
la première fois qu'ils font du théâtre
et sentent pas forcément capables
d'apprendre des kilomètres et des
kilomètres de texte
pas de problème on va écrire vous
adapter en fonction de chacun que celle
des capacités aussi hélas les positions
qu'on peut l'envié voilà merci
damien croise alors c'est quand qu'on
arrive c'est le vendredi 26 janvier à
l'espace albert camus de maurepas ya
d'autres dates rossi dans ce festival le
13 janvier ce sera l'atout de la troupe
du crâne donc on a vu tout à l'heure où
ils joueront le bourgeois gentilhomme de
molière et le 20 janvier c'est tandem
qui jouera sur les planches d'après les
textes jean claude allègre un peu de
cinéma maintenant si les chiffres sont
un peu en baisse par rapport à 2016
l'année 2010 est du cinéma fait partie
des trois meilleures années depuis 50 en
2017 c'est donc près de 210 millions
d'entrées et meilleur score c'est pour
raide dingue de dany boon et moi moche
et méchant le troisième alors que nous
réserve l'année 2018 regarder jouer
[Musique]
quinze ans qu'elle est attendue la suite
des aventures de la famille de super
héros sort au mois de juillet un des
rendez vous internationaux de 2018
une année ou deux grands noms vont se
côtoyer steven spielberg
woody allen ou encore clint eastwood
woody allen et clint eastwood alors il
ya deux catégories de films art et essai
ce sont des films art et essai
ostracisant woody allen clint eastwood
est à l'arrêt ses porteurs comme on dit
dans le jargon du métier c'est assez les
films de grands cils
connus qui ont pignon sur rue alors des
fois on a des surprises il ya des films
qui qui font des gros succès comme ça et
qu'ils sortent qui sont des surprises
tout simplement parce que le réalisateur
est pas connue et cetera elle le cinéma
français ne sera pas en reste la
nouvelle comédie de dany boon lâcheté de
famille sans en février le 31 janvier le
public pourra aussi découvrir le
troisième volet des aventures des tuche
les français aiment beaucoup la comédie
alors après j'ai pas vu les films dont
il faut qu'il soit réussi
les tuche en général ça marche très bien
c'est olivier baroux qui réalise comme
les deux premiers épisodes
bon ben vous connaissez tous les tuche
enfin j'imagine
cette famine comment dirais-je de de bof
on va dire entre guillemets s'en
occupent des chansons qui se retrouvent
dans des situations complètement
hallucinante et parce qu'une année
cinéma sans un nouveau star wars n'en
est pas une
le 23 mai ron howard vous embarque dans
le passé de han solo et on reparle de
théâtre avec nos deux nouveaux invités
stéphane nado alain laurent lancer tous
les deux de l'association à pas de
géants installés à guyancourt
oui pas d'erreur déjà c'est ça alors
pourra pas de géant c'est pour réduit à
guyancourt sur des échasses des artistes
du nouveau théâtre
oui qu'est ce que c'est que cette
association alors c'est une association
qui fait du théâtre mais de façon
générale c'est à dire qu'on
des ateliers d'improvisation théâtrale
pour les adolescents et les adultes et
du théâtre dit traditionnel pour les
enfants donc les décès de balayer au
plus large vraiment rendre accessible le
théâtre la scène à tous tout à fait oui
je vais à partir de 6 ans jusqu'à 20
sans limite en fait avec avec l'impro et
en plus justement on profite de l'impro
et ses différentes influences et
popularisation alors c'était décret en
oui sauf erreur de ma part vous êtes
aujourd'hui presque soixante adhérents
s'est bien installée vous avez toujours
peut-être des familles réf oui on a pour
la petite anecdote par exemple l'atelier
des enfants qui aujourd'hui un des deux
qui a animé par une ancienne adhérente
qui avait à l'époque comme dans 15 ans
ou peut-être qu'il reste voilà
associations si on passe le flambeau
alors plus jeunes du théâtre plutôt
classique alors on dit bien plus tôt
pour pas lui dont la lasagne septième
alors justement qu'est ce que vous leur
apprenez ce sont les bases des pièces
classiques sont alors complètement écrit
en fait par les deux animateurs
d'ateliers en fonction du groupe qu'ils
ont des aspirations qu'ils ont de l'
envie du moment ça peut être une base
prix et tout est développé autour des
pièces originales
vous n'allez pas peut-être j'ai du
molière non non non non c'est vraiment
des pièces modernes contemporaines enfin
de deux ans va dire que oui non pour
certaines qu'elles sont pas servir de
base sur des pièces écrites lave dans
les années 2000 voire fin des années 90
quand on dit nous on parle de théâtre
traditionnel pour dire qu'il ya un
support écrit à une pièce écrite en
aspect plutôt saine et moi improvisation
voilà c'est ce que vous passez aux
adolescents lors des douze ans où il
un âge limite entre les 12 et les ados
pour l'impro ben en fait le lhc qu'un
chiffre on prend les adolescents à
l'impro à partir de 14 ans j'ai plutôt
envie de dire niveau 4e pour pour être
moins précis parce qu'à 14 enfin un
enfant de 13 ans peut aussi déjà être
très à l'aise sur scène voilà avoir les
codes et faire de l'impro très
facilement alors que un enfant de 12 ans
aussi mais après c'est pas on est ce que
c'est voilà justement l'improvisation
qu'est ce que vous leur apprenez
qu'est-ce que alors on fait du théâtre
un peu traditionnelle aussi il ya le
travail de la voix le placement l'eia il
ya la rencontre avec le public
et puis il ya la spontanéité en fait on
réapprend aux gens alors que là je parle
des adultes c'est ce que j'ai moi en
atelier à refaire ce qu'on faisait dans
la cour d'école tout simplement là
maintenant je suis une sorcière
vas-y prends ton ballet fin voilà c'est
ça c'est ça parce qu'on a tous fait ça
dans une cour
quand on était enfant puis on a un peu
perdu ses réflexes mais sont pas très
loin de cacher en fin de compte alors
les plus jeunes d'horizons spectacle
pour dire à la fin de l'année où il
restitue de tous leurs apprentissages
pour l'impro il ya quand même un
calendrier à respecter un peu plus
précis parce que vous participez au
championnat d'improvisation de la ligue
tout à la ligue d'improvisation des
yvelines
oui c'est un entraînement régulier
important c'est d'aider scène
des scènes supplémentaires avec ses
parts à l'enjeu de participer au
championnat mais c'est de rencontrer des
équipes voisines
et puis du coup d'avoir un déroulé sur
l'année enfin le on aime se représenter
donc c'est un peu l'idée en
improvisation c'est de se confronter au
public le plus souvent possible alors
dans le descriptif de l'association il
ya aussi échasses le e de géant
ça c'est quelque chose que vous proposez
tous les deux oui tout à fait mais pas
nos adhérents mais effectivement
stéphanie et moi on fait des animations
de rue sur la chasse en beaucoup sur lui
en cours même
on se diversifie aussi on fait aussi des
fêtes d'école sur mon signer enfin voila
c'est très particulier comme on
recommence en est venu à découvrir les
échasses passé c'est vraiment
historiquement celle inverse
on a participé adolescents dans une
maison de quartier on habitait
guyancourt tous les deux et on a
participé à un atelier de des chasses
avec un petit peu de spectacles de rue
et tout part de là en fin de compte
l'association même à son historique dans
cette pratique de l'époque vous sa part
recruter puisque vous êtes bénévole vous
êtes professionnel comment ça se passe
chez vous tous bénévoles tous les
professeurs les c'est pour ça qu'ils on
les appelle pas professeurs animateurs
peut être animateur coach enfin voila
c'est des nuances mais bon on est tous
tous bénévoles et on donne tous notre
temps avec grand plaisir et donc vous
prenez chaque année seul enfant qui veut
à la sortie de l'école faire des cours
de théâtre
il peut aller chez vous sans soucis sans
souci dans la mesure où on peut encore
l'accueillir donc on a en se fixant un
quota d'enfants est de même pour les
adolescents les adultes pour ça reste à
un cours
c'est ça qu'on apprenne quelque chose
c'est ça merci à tous les deux d'être
venu en plat chaud gens priaient ce que
je peux rajouter justin calais les aux
antilles justement on a un match
d'improvisation avec avec les adultes
voilà le 13 janvier sur concours tout à
fait c'est ça c'était la merci de la
précision
juste avant de nous quitter pour
terminer les missions un jeu concours
vous pouvez gagner des places pour don
quichotte au prisme le 12 janvier
prochain pour participer rien de plus
simple rendez vous sur le site internet
de la chaîne tv 78 points comme c'est la
fin de ce set une culture je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve maître du prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]